okay well yeah
start live streaming thank you
okay welcome everybody to
the may 3rd infrastructure services
committee meeting
um i'm going to start with apologies
we have councillor sopa
lindsay mckenzie
and councillor kit can i have someone
move that they'll be accepted council
ludlow seconded
miss coot put that motion all those in
favor
against the motion is carried uh zoom
attendees we have councillor abbott and
councillor clark
and we're going to start with public
forum right like to welcome members
of the indica police force would you
like to come forward
[Music]
we have
mike bowman we have john bisset and
holly mahindi
welcome
so i believe the subject is about cctv
and you may remove your masks
to speak
okay mike welcome uh thank you thanks uh
members of the of this uh council to
invite us along to talk to the inner
cities um ctv's
the
reason for this uh
request to come and talk to you is uh is
basically you may recall back in 2015 i
come and spoke to the council
and spoke to this
the need for new cameras then
and and i think i i started off with our
vision for the new zealand police is
that we new zealand is the safest
country in new zealand and i said why
can't we
be the safest city in new zealand and to
do that we need our community to feel
safe and be safe
and we think
an upgrade of the cctv cameras will
enable us to be a
a good point for
people who are wanting to come into a
new vibrant city
and
and will come into a recovery room and
be safe and we're not not including
uh the invercargill city cbd we're
actually talking the whole city
because that's
uh we want invercargill to be safe we
want people in our community to be safe
and and i think the proposal we have
to put for you today
is about boldness boldness of this
committee
to invest
in a
much more wider
cctv platform
across
not just the inner city cbd but also
wider aspects of uh the community and i
you know i highlight the thing the fact
that you have invested heavily in
improving the
uh infrastructures or the the uh
shopping centers such as southern
invercargill south and vicar and north
indica so why not keep them people safe
as well
but look i want to invite
my my team uh john inspector johnny
bissett who's my area prevention manager
and and sergeant holly mahini who's
recently appointed to our prevention
manager who had prepared a powerpoint
presentation to give you some more
clarity around why we need uh this
upgrade johnny yeah unfortunately we're
not going to be able to get that to run
on the screen for you but i will we'll
talk to the kind of the topics that we
talked about so
i guess the
well what we're trying to um
indicate to you really is around the the
point mike made around there's real
opportunity in being really bold in
terms of
you know investing in
some infrastructure that
creates an environment right across the
city where people will feel safe
now
we know through our history and
throughout the country and around the
world right there's clear examples where
cctv
systems
that are put together
well and are
spread out across
the area will have a deterrence effect
in terms of
a number of issues that relate to
policing
and a number of issues that also enhance
that community safety feeling so the big
obvious one is serious crime for us
you know we have a number of serious
incidents that do tend to occur in
uh predictable locations and that is uh
areas that attract high foot traffic
um or locations of interest like your um
bars nightclubs
uh vulnerable locations such as banks
and that type of thing so you know
there's a clear example that the of the
week just gone by with the tragic
homicide that occurred here in don
street in the cargo
fortunately we have some cctv
of that incident
however that is not city council cctv
and the city council
tv hasn't helped us and then in quarry
at all
and and that's a real shame
from my perspective there's a whole lot
of
uh opportunity in that space where
investment
right across the city will greatly
enhance the safety of the individual and
ultimately
assist us in holding some of those
people to account
there's a number of other areas that we
wanted to briefly speak to one is around
vulnerable people
in the last 12 months we've had around
about 193 missing people in the city
and
427 calls for people who are intending
to self-harm
often people who intend to self-harm
go mobile and that when i say mobile i
mean they'll jump in their vehicles and
they'll take off and these are people's
families their loved ones
um and and they're in a time of real
crisis in need
and currently the means by which we can
locate these people is very limited
the investment into a good cctv system
that is well thought out across
the cargo city
will enable us to find these people
quicker and give them the help that they
need
we had an example we can reference um
where we really tragically couldn't find
mr roman horn who went missing in queens
park well it's just another example of
where
uh cctv investment can have tangible
outcomes and for the community
and the last topic that we were um
wanting to talk to
just before we give you a sort of a
summary was around our volume crime so
you know this is a frustrating piece of
of our of our job but we had 550
burglaries in invercargill city in the
last 12 months
with 254 stolen vehicles now those two
crime types are linked we know that
some of our
people that we
hold responsible for these
crimes
do steal motor vehicles and travel
around and commit crime
well really sadly we have people come
from out of the city into our city in a
stolen car and commit a series of crimes
we have an opportunity again through
a bold investment
like mike said
to really build an infrastructure that
gets us in front of that which gives us
an opportunity to prevent a whole lot of
harm
caused by people that don't even live in
our city and and we really have the
opportunity and the last kind of thing
i'd just touch on was the
the the trend you've seen in the media
recently around
youth crime or ram raids that have been
happening in the north island
really unfortunately the history tells
us that
what we see up country
uh tends to make its way down and we
will likely see that type of offending
in the year or years to come
again
we believe
now is the time to make an investment
where we could tangibly have an impact
in preventing that
and i think um
uh it's really important
so holly want to talk about our current
stay so currently there are nine uh
inner city cctv cameras that we monitor
from the station
as it stands at the moment what only one
of those cameras works
and it is the one
that faces from calvin onto dawn street
[Music]
the current state of it is that
whether it's day or night we cannot see
number plates we cannot recognise faces
we can get a rough colour
of their clothing or of the car another
case in point where it would have been a
great tool to have as recently a police
officer was
attacked in his vehicle
right under a cctv camera that
should be operating in d street that was
not
and unfortunately we've had to go to a
member of the public in a private home
to access footage which also is not
great
so
the current what we have
at the moment is not fit for purpose
and it's a real gap that we have to
assist the people that we serve
so ultimately like what we're saying is
is that
what we have is very limited it's
almost into quite a technology now
what we would have got in terms of
investment or we although council would
have got in terms of investment
previously you'll now get a far more
uh greater system in terms of that
because of the way technology has moved
what we are asking for i guess is that
is and i guess the
i guess a challenge from us is around
the opportunity to be bold is now how do
we how do we invest in creating an
environment where everyone feels safe
um we'll have a whole lot of tangible
outcomes in terms of the prevention of
crime
yes there's a really uh also a good uh
assistance to us in terms of
investigating serious crime
and um
for us it's more a question of what you
know i can't think of a reason why you
wouldn't
i think to finish off is you are
investing heavily in the inner city
development why not invest into this to
encourage uh
not just invocable people to come into
the inner city but also rural and
visitors to come to southland and and be
safe in in in the environment of
invercargill this is the opportunity and
i think it's an opportunity that uh
we as a as a community
want
thanks um
john holly and mike i'm going to open up
now to uh questions
right um
we'll start with the zoom people and
then
uh councillor clark
yeah thank you chair and uh welcome to
mike and his team um just a couple
things you might be able to contribute
on mike um one of the things that we've
been focused on i guess is it's not
necessarily the
resolution of crime
but more on which is the
making the city safe but it's more about
feeling safe and you heard people talk
about something you'll start talking
about feeling safe yes and it's been a
concern for myself and certainly
councilor partners been raising us for
forever
around the need for women and children
to be safe in the inner city
and it's not necessarily from somebody
that might murder them as we saw on don
street um or do a ramray but at a lower
level it's just from loutish behavior
and behaviour that needs intervention
from the police not necessarily at a
senior a criminal level but probably at
at an interventional level where a
strong word and people realize that if
they do silly things in the inner city
uh they'll see somebody in blue
so just wondering about your thoughts on
that
i think i think you're right i think
it's it's not about it's not just about
apprehending offenders it's also about
being able to observe patterns patterns
of behaviour and look at prevention
opportunities what prevention
opportunities can we look at not just
the police as a community to implement
to try and
stop um
behaviors that might be
as you
identified as
deterring people from feeling safe in
the community so this is this is just
one tool that we can be utilizing
but i think it also the message it sends
to people who want to come and uh come
into the community and come into the
environment and cause issues is there's
a high likelihood with the upgraded
technology that you will get identified
and you will be made to account
sure
thanks thank you councilman councillor
abbott
yeah thanks for that and uh thanks for
your attendance here today uh my audio
is a little bit suspect at the moment
but i think i picked up that you said
you had nine or we had nine cameras
within the inner city periphery and i
think i picked up that the one from
calvin street that zoomed up to
the
the homicide didn't work am i right that
is the only one that is working
fortunately
and it did work but you couldn't see
anything from it
no that's a great tip
okay right thank you
okay councilman uh council lewis and
then thanks cheers
thank you mike john and holly thank you
very much um
three aspects of the cameras and i can
see
the prevention because they're there
there's the monitoring and the problems
over the the crime solving so what sort
of percentage would you be hoping for
with
uh well i think i think
at the present time
the possibility of getting a successful
outcome from the existing cameras would
be less than five percent
uh and that's because we've only got one
camera and the quality is poor but i
think if you've got uh a much a much
more extensive uh range of uh coverage
with better technology you'd have to be
looking uh 60 to 70 percent uh and the
only thing that would deter that is
perhaps poor lighting or the fact that
um
they were wearing some sort of disguise
or a mask or something but once you get
a face
to start a start an inquiry that's this
year that's can save so much time
there's there's also a really uh like uh
potential indirect benefit to us so
um by example the
mr horn who unfortunately missing in the
park there's thousands of man hours
invested in that search
um
you know that's potentially thousands of
man hours we could be investing into
solving someone's burglary from the
house
or preventing someone from dying on our
roads
and so the the
benefit
is through that cell cost savings yes
agree 100 the
prevention is the foremost key and i
think that there would be a reduction
automatically through that through the
implementation the system we would work
really hard
to assist you in promotion of that
um
i don't know if we could give you a an
actual percentage in terms of what we
predict would reduce by crime if you
wished we could potentially go away and
look at what's happened around the world
to try to understand the impacts you
know london by example has a fairly
complex cctv system
and there are other examples but
there is huge in my view um
cross benefits to the system
okay thank you
because
exactly the overseas the
united kingdom one you see on crime
problems and they can track everybody
down they can predict the person's going
to lift up their hand before they've
done it
thank you council lewis next time can
you use the microphone um we've got
councillor arnold then council ludlow
and ms cooke and your worship i'll put
you on the list
questions very simple questions um you
did allude to the fact these cameras
that we have now are very old
was do you have any percentages of
or numbers from earlier on were they
helpful earlier on when they all worked
was there
i think they were beneficial uh when
they when the
no i couldn't tell you but
i think what we had the ability then was
to that it was clearer uh even though it
wasn't the greatest technology but in
those days it was greater than nothing
that's right and it just gives us an
ability
uh if you find out if we get information
that something's occurring at a specific
location
we can quickly zoom the cameras and if
there's a camera close to it and start
to monitor the behaviors we at the very
least we those days we could get some
description of clothing so that staff
could have been more aware of what was
going on before they arrived so it's a
start safety aspect as well do you have
oh that's three questions do you have
somebody there do you guys monitor it uh
we have we have to be there all the
uh we have the camera set up
we used to use a community patrols uh to
help monitor those as well but also we
have the ability of we always have a
staff member on duty in the watch house
who if they get a call can um can come
and monitor the the cctvs uh or um the
specific camera can move the camera to
accordingly to where the problem might
be arising but we do we do utilize the
community patrols quite heavily for that
as well my next question is um
because of your experience do you guys
have an idea where the cameras should
actually be placed because you know
where your trouble spots are so from our
point of view you could say well we
probably need 72 cameras these are the
sites that we would recommend that
they'd be in you you have a
yeah we've been working up a like a
draft proposal if you like to hopefully
work with the council's team around
what they looks like you know i think
there's some some really obvious places
you know that the this inner city is an
obvious one that you'd i guess what i
would refer to as being a live zone so
you want most of the inner city area to
be live where anywhere you walk you're
seen on a cctv camera
then as you move out to the suburbs you
move to put like a positional type
camera on intersections where we have
automated number plate recognition
systems in the camera it'll pick up
stolen vehicles
vehicles that are interest to us
um vehicles are people who are um in
need of our help
um that type of approach i think that
from my point of view would be would be
very helpful because then we would know
kind of
what it's um is that a question the next
question no that's not to follow on but
my last question is um
you've mentioned the burglary thing
before uh people coming into town and
doing burglaries obviously you're
responsible to
make a response you know
quickly if you'd like to uh
whereas you know the rumors uh very
gregory responses is not good
you know the delays have you got a plan
in place to
well what you would like you know you be
on to it straight away what target and
well what you think about is uh
particularly rural burglaries or uh
rural burglaries or town bridges
yeah but what you if we get the cameras
in the right location that enables us to
if we get description of vehicles we can
then uh look for those vehicles at extra
points for uh the city uh crucial and
extra exports and see try and track the
movements beforehand or afterwards to
try and see if we can identify offenders
because sometimes we don't get notified
about burglaries until some hours later
on but
where we have the capability of a simple
thing is a description of a car then we
can look for those those common
denominators and some of their entry
points into the city logical infantry
points or extra points out of the city i
guess what because you're saying is if
you had enough cameras you'd be able to
check
absolutely movements
the two crime types of stolen motor
vehicles and burglary are quite closely
linked we know that
they participate in both those
activities
so
whilst the cameras aren't there to
address burglary we will detect stolen
motor vehicles and be able to have a
tangible impact in that which will
reduce
burglary
we will know when a stolen car arrives
in our city and be able to take some
affirmative action which we would every
time
to
intercept that vehicle and prevent what
they were coming here to do whether
that's burglary or some other crime type
um
you know the transportation of illicit
substances is another one that often
organized crime groups will use
motor vehicles
that are stolen or
flagged by us
and it gives us the ability to be
proactive in that space around when they
arrive rather than trying to
follow them down but when they've left
okay thank you thank you councillor
arnold
i think one thing that i
i think you should understand is they
don't just get monitored in invercargill
they get monitored in their command
center in dunedin and they also get
monitored in their command center in
wellington so in wellington they can
zoom in across the country who are off
centers who have uh cameras uh and so
likewise in our command center in
dunedin can look at invercargill dunedin
and the likes of queenstown and wanaka
as well so they have a good wide range
of uh visibility across the district
around what's happening
okay i'm going to go to councillor
ludlow then miss coote then his worship
and then council skill
one and i'll keep it quick i'm
recognizing that technology has moved
from the one barely functioning
kelvin street camera to we've gone from
there to high definition to 4k to 8k
to also
nighttime visibility cameras where you
couldn't tell the difference between
night and day but what
we're going to need to know is numbers
and locations and and cost
and that's how long do you think it
would take to to get that sort of
information back to us
we were hoping god
and forgive me we're probably not sort
of thought that far ahead but we were
sort of thinking we would work with
someone from the council to shape up
what so so answering that and the in the
item later on that actually
delves into a
group of
people to bring that information back
and actually achieve that yeah
i'm going to go now to quickly go to
miss coote
then there's worship and then councillor
scott and we'll have to wrap up the
public forum okay thank you very much
and i think uh councillor laddo actually
just asked my question which i was
really curious about i do want to
acknowledge that um
yeah the work that you're doing out
there is amazing
and that the cameras that worked
sufficiently at the time are no longer
fit for purpose so we really need to be
exploring that further so thank you for
bringing it to our attention
okay your worship
yes well just thank you from behalf of
the city for all the sterling work that
you do in this area
but
i was here when we had the original
cameras
and
it was
a furious debate took place because
they were going to cost twenty thousand
dollars per camera
is that
sort of a decreasing cost
because of
technology which i thought was going to
get cheaper by the day or was it just
such a superior system
with the with the
improvements in their systems uh with
cameras now
your value for money is much is a lot
better you can get much better quality
and numbers of cameras for a lot less
money now so you're getting
much better quality for a good
for a good good funding
okay thank you worship um councillor
skelt
thank thankfully through you cheer um i
just want to endorse thanks to new
zealand for the work that's been done
and particularly in recent times
that's always been a fantastic job
um just to help with councillor lewis's
question regarding the
clarity of cameras and so on um and i've
i'll come to a direct question a moment
but council lewis i'll give you an
example there's a venue with 22 cameras
in the other city a sports venue
which is invested heavily in cameras
the apprehension rate rate around that
is about 95 percent
of the culprits that may be causing
crime scout the question well no it
leads to i'm answering council lewis has
to move to the question so it gives
detail as to the number of and that's
the question i'm coming to
for for uh mr bowman and his colleagues
so
it's imperative in the sense of the
extensiveness of what we're doing
uh mr bowman has mentioned um
the number of cameras and so on the
clarity i'm really interested in and the
ability going back to the watch house
obviously so it's about vehicle
recognition correct it's about facial
recognition
i think in in the right area right so
different areas have different
requirement types if you like so if
you're looking at a at the inner city
cbd if you're looking around night clubs
or high pedestrian areas where
you know the crime type that you're
trying to prevent
or to make people feel safe from as is
into person
then that's a somewhere where you want
to have cameras that are high definition
you can make out uh identify someone on
their face
if we're talking about now we move out
into the suburbs and and entry exit
points into the city that's where we
start to look at we want uh we would
recommend that the camera is a number
plate recognition system
and i think um
you know like we would try to work with
a with some technical expertise to try
and understand what would be the best
fit but i think it would be a mixture
across the city and
thank you that was the reasoning for the
engagement around the questioning thank
you
i'm going to fit councillor amundsen and
that's it it's a quick question um i'm
just wondering given that it's um a tool
that the police use
why do councils have to pay for these
sorry to ask but
well i think it's i think it's a it's a
community responsibility um because it's
it's not a police and responsibility to
have cameras in in the in the community
i think of the council i think it's it's
they own this the the community uh we
are part of that community and we are
only a part where we are there to try
and keep people safe the council's view
the
position should be that they want to
encourage people to come into their
community they should encourage people
to want to be safe and i think that's
where you should be and you are you're
investing heavily in the community
right across the city
to encourage people to reinvest into the
community to get engaged in it and to do
that this is a small part of it
is that that's your question yeah yeah i
think if you
reference back to the um the policing
act the core policing functions
uh defined in that
building uh infrastructure is in one i
think it's a community
um responsibility
okay hey thanks guys thanks holly mike
and john
thank you very much we talking about
this item later on today and uh there's
a few recommendations that we'll have to
vote on
thank you so much
right that
takes us now to the minutes of the
extraordinary infrastructure services
meeting of april
2022
can i have someone please move that
we're wrong
thank you council rabbit seconded
councillor lewis i'll put that motion
all those in favor
against the motion that's carried
i'm going to move now to the minutes of
the infrastructure services
committee services committee 5th of
april
2022.
can i have someone please move to be
received
moved
council amundsen seconded
ms coote
i'll put that motion all those in favor
against that is carried and it was a
busy day the fifth of april we're going
now
to the minutes of the
extraordinary
uh infrastructure services committee
meeting fifth of april 2022.
can someone please move
thank you
miss cook seconded
council lewis put that all those in
favor
against
carrick
right that now takes us to the
deliberations
on the stormwater bylaw consultation
and we have
uh to the koto councillors today we
table an amended stormwater by-law
post-consultation with the public for
deliberations
a quick refresh on the process to date
the draft stormwater bylaw was adopted
for consultation on the second to feb
and was at the consultation with the
public from the 4th of feb to the 7th of
march
we received a total of 13 submissions
on the draft bylaw
a mix of commercial entities and private
community members
seven submitters supported the bylaw
sick supported it but with some
suggested amendments
no submitters were against the
introduction of a by-law
hearings were held on the 5th of april
where you heard from six submitters
from the submissions and the hearings
there are a number of points raised and
council officers have considered these
some of these points have been accepted
and mine amendments are recommended to
the by-law
there were other points for example
industry-specific exclusions that were
considered
however it is not recommended to include
these it was felt it could weaken
council's ability to improve the water
quality and deal with possible
contamination events
we also wish to present the guidance
manual to the committee which provides
greater granularity on the consenting
process
stormwater discharge contamination
guideline values
stormwater management plans and sediment
and erosion control plans
i'll now pass across to our technical
experts who may wish to add a point or
two than happy to answer any questions
that council may have
thank you
cara michael i'm your stormwater
technical officer here at the council
um so i'll be speaking to the guidance
manual
sorry i'll bring that closer
you want to hear me now
fantastic um so i'll be speaking about
the guidance manual
so
a couple of the points that were raised
by some of our submitters were
speaking to specific guideline guidance
values for contamination events
so they wanted to know specifically to
what level they could put in
traditionally we haven't seen this
through other bylaws in the throughout
the country
they generally
are fairly vague
but it's getting to the point now where
guidance values
have to be submitted so what we have is
the guidance values
as used by our stormwater discharge
consent
so
they're on the they are allowed to
discharge to the same level that we're
allowed to discharge to the receiving
water so
no better no less than what we're
allowed to do ourselves
so these are the values that we're going
to use going forward
so any
any site or business or premises is not
allowed to discharge
stormwater
containing contaminants any worse than
what city council is allowed to
discharge itself to the receiving waters
um we've also added
um
some information on how to conduct a
sediment and erosion control plan
one of the submitters uh suggested that
it may have been an error that we use in
environment canterbury's uh sediment and
erosion control plan
with no disrespect to environment
southland
environment canterbury's is far more
comprehensive
and it has a step-by-step
step-by-step user manual on on how to
submit and create sediment erosion so
hopefully that will stop
sediments going onto our roads
and into the kerbside channel into our
stormwater network and into our
receiving waters
also as a part of this is obviously the
application to connect stormwater to our
stormwater network through new builds so
um subdivisions that's more with so it's
more of jeremy's team
um
other than that i'm happy to ask any
questions anyone has
right jeremy do you want to speak before
we open up for questions um no i'll
tackle any questions that
might pop up right okay so i'm going to
open
for questions your worship
yes sir um i'm just wondering if
there's virtually no
opposition to it because
uh the price isn't mentioned
and
do you think there would have been more
interest in it
if there'd been
costs involved
yes
uh i guess it's a bit difficult to
answer your worship so
when we put this out the
report to adopt the consultation talked
about you know possibly needing to get
extra staff and some money being
allocated towards an education plan
around that so we did put that out when
we consulted and i've also believe in
the annual plan consultation some of the
increases near reflective of
what we're coming through with the
stormwater proposed bylaws
any further questions
yes council lewis thank you chad just a
very quick one accidental discharge i.e
a car smash um drive train failure in
the motor vehicle would could result in
a lot of oil
being straightened in storm water
penalties for that or
or dealing with such a situation
um unforeseen incidences uh will be
doubt as such um
we will always always be going for an
educational
process first
infringement isn't our first protocol uh
car crashes
um unless they were doing something
horrendously stupid
um we would consider infringement in
that in that situation um but always
education first which one
counselor
in amongst horrendously stupid would you
include the spelling of diesel for
sustained loss of attraction
right further questions
okay
thank you for that report that takes us
to the recommendations
we have
six recommendations to the committee
that we received the report
we received the amended stormwater by
law
we received the
stormwater bylaw guidance manual
we note the submissions received
by the infrastructure services committee
on the 5th of april
we also note the summary of submissions
and we note the social media reports so
those
six recommendations would someone like
to
move those as a group
moved councillor arminson seconded
councillor scalp i'm going to put those
put that motion all those in favor
against that's carrot that takes us next
to the recommendation
to counsel
which
sorry
oh councillor cricket
um thank you mr chair i just like it
noted um my abstention from the vote i
wasn't here at the meeting where we were
um viewing submissions and i haven't
also had a chance to review the online
footage so although i've read it and
it's very clear that it's very well
supported in the community i'll just be
abstaining for um clarity and accuracy
sake okay that's noted thanks okay so
we now have the recommendation to
council which is
number seven and that includes
uh through to
a to n for the uh amendments
okay so unless there is an objection
from anyone i would uh
can i have someone please move that we
adopt a revised stormwater bylaw which
incorporates the following changes
following consultation a through to in
i'd move them in their entirety
thank you councillor abbott abbott
second councillor arnold i'm going to
put that all those in favor
against
they are carried
okay
sorry miss
could you note me as an abstention
please as an organisation of which i am
the chair was a submitter okay right
no that as well
right thanks guys
that now
takes us
to review of parks and reserve
land
phase one so i take it there's going to
be more of this
okay who would like to speak
i would like to speak
thank you
it's very close to working there we go
so you quite rightly no chair that is
phase one of the review of parks and
reserves land um thank you all for
previously coming to a workshop where we
discussed the review
so that review
was undertaken on
looking at land managed by the city
council parks and recreation team
and this report actually summarizes
that review and identifies the potential
land that we look for
i suppose that phase one the ones that
we thought could be um
easily disposed of so that is land that
costs us to manage
and we receive a little or no beneficial
use from the community for this
so we're looking at five initial pieces
of land which total 1.5 hectares three
freehold two reserve land
um
and going through this land
the recommendations are to receive the
report and also to endorse proceeding
with disposal and that disposal is
following the process as defined in the
park's
disposal policy
thank you anyone else
to speak
uh no sorry from the staff
no no okay i'm gonna open up for
questions counselor arnold uh just a
quick question i just uh noticed the um
piece of land in scott street
uh would actually have no access is that
a
is that an issue that you've sort of
thought about that
it could only really be bought by
somebody who's got a front section
yes but it's just that's the way it is
we'll just
break it up with yourself to two or
three of them more
um
that's that's the investigation that we
would need to do proceeding with this
now is actually find out whether we do
have interest in that land that's quite
a big change
it is one of the reasons why it's been
put forward because it's very difficult
for us to manage with that access
yeah well you got no access
why are the schools or
yeah
okay further questions
council ladlo
not a question chair i guess you're
looking for someone to to move the
recommendations and i'm prepared to
although i will note that
in
recommendation too
i think this might be the second time
i've
moved that we um proceed with disposing
of 794 queens drive i think it did come
up before council once before and was
never actioned but
good luck this time yeah you are correct
though
so i'll move the recommendations to you
okay so you're moving recommendations
one and two
receive the report and two that's items
a through to e can i have a second of
that councillor scott second uh i'm
going to put that motion all those in
favor
hello against that is carrick thank you
good luck with the others
right now we follow from our public
forum
subject uh cctv we
um russell do you wanna present this
okay good afternoon councilman mr chair
um
i've prepared this report
um i guess it's part of an ongoing um
discussion we've had with cctv over a
period of time and perhaps i could just
make some
general comments to my report i guess
with any project there are many many
many tools that you can develop and cctv
is one of those tools that we have for
our city centre
so as part of that under the options of
that i've presented is that i did i have
created i guess those three options
which identify um where council wants to
sit and
in terms of providing the
cctv and the recommendation that sits
under recommendation too is that we
carry on and we are probably one of the
better placed organizations to be able
to lead or drive or coordinate that
management of the cctv
i do recognise that the current cctv is
at the end of its life and we have had a
all the technology that we have sits at
the police station and we attend upon
request
and as you can imagine and
me sitting at the back hearing none of
the working um a contract has already
been advised that we need to be there
and actually identify what some of those
issues are
we need to also make sure that the
technology is fit for purpose and we've
heard about today some of the things
that technology could do but part of
that needs to be i guess is part of the
wider plan
what which ones of those as a community
we do actually wish to actually
implement which includes facial
recognition number plate recognition
and i guess it's that's the wider issue
about where this all goes across the
city and that's um you know i have a
thing that just got to watch that we
don't play lightning strike um we run to
where we've been we do need to have have
the ability to be agile and for our
technology to actually be able to
deliver the technology across the wider
city
which will include our i guess
shopping centers bluff and elsewhere
where we want to provide the same level
of
i guess
coverage
this initial report's really tried to
start to focus on our study center work
but whatever the technology is that we
implement and start it needs to be
adaptable and expandable such that we
can add to it as we need
um
obviously we have other cctv networks
which include our parks and some of our
buildings which we will need to be able
to migrate to those systems so that we
can have it robust on the way forward
and the police did
help me quite a bit today they said that
we needed it to be well thought needs to
be a structure and we need to have some
boldness about what we do here
and i guess my report looks to start
that process by establishing what i
believe is probably the key to actually
get this going into a point is actually
creating a i might call it a late a
stakeholder leadership group so that you
can actually have that level of
knowledge that you that you need on that
group to actually drive this to actually
be
be manageable within the community but
also deliver the technology and carry on
i think we heard a little bit about
making sure that there was monitoring
that's needed because this equipment
records if you don't actually use it all
the time then it won't be as effective
as it can be
and in that group i've also suggested
that
the community patrol group has a has a
voice which is an opportunity to be
participate because they are often the
people that support the police during
the weekends
technology is working in our favor and
things that were worth twenty thousand
dollars a few years ago are certainly
much cheaper
we also need to make sure that as we do
things around the community that we use
wi-fi
um our own cabling and all that i guess
other technical bits and pieces that
actually make them work in the remote
places the further you get away from the
city centre the harder this is but it is
now possible with the technology that is
available to us
so i'm happy to present the report and
ask
answer any questions
just firstly i just want to touch on the
financial implications and that's
obviously the budget
um it's noted as three hundred thousand
dollars now going back to 2015
when we first sort of touched on this or
maybe a bit earlier
i remember a
budget of two thousand dollars being
already there
um
as reserves or that it was the money was
already allocated
i got a pretty good memory
and uh so is this are we finding 300 000
new dollars or
do we have
an existing reserves that we've been
um
putting money aside or that
it goes back to 2015.
um if mike would like me to answer that
when i'm happy to do so um my
recollection was that that money
was
identified as a as a budget and through
our process we have changed from having
reserves to a net debt
and as part of that process what we're
seeing is that this money is now being
budgeted and brought forward into the
um so the money hasn't gone away it's
just now being brought forward to be
spent okay now let's answer that sorry
go back uh i'll start with the zoom
people and councillor clark
thank you chad just two issues really
um from what we heard from the police
today it seems to me that that they're
wanting a much wider
uh platform i guess than than what we
probably initially envisioned which was
the cbd
so from what i recall they said cbd
windsor south city bluff
and exit and entry points into the city
so that that make does that make the um
project much bigger bigger than what
you've costed for
mr chair that would be correct but i
think part of the part of the process
needs to be
let's establish what the scope of the
project is so that you can put the
numbers to it i guess what we're
suggesting is that there's this budget
available
and depending on what other
infrastructure and the wider technology
that you need to support this this is
just not about cameras this is about
having recording devices this is cabling
or wi-fi units that you've got to put in
place let's see what we actually truly
do need and as that project is scoped
then we can bring it back to council
with
greater clarity around what the
financial implications will be and who
might support it
and just a final question share which is
really for yourself
given that you've been pushing for this
for a long long time
and your
expertise in the field is 300 000 a
realistic figure for
a city-wide
network
look
300 000 is actually i would have to
compliment that budget because that's
very realistic to give you an idea i was
i was not going to
um
give any details on costings and stuff
but to answer his worship's question
with a twenty thousand 000 camera um a
very suitable
say six mega pixel camera installed
uh you're looking around two thousand
dollars i would i would guess so
um you know work it from there you've
still got the recording you know the
um
the recording technology but at 300 000
i would say is a very very well thought
out budget
thank you
so mr chair one of the things that we
are fortunate of is that we do have
a relatively extensive
fibre network ourselves around the city
that actually connect their businesses
which gives us probably a more unique
opportunity to be able to connect
cameras to those networks and run the
high
i guess the high definition cameras that
you have to do to get what the police
are looking for so we do actually have a
whole lot of that infrastructure that
we've been consolidating over the last
few years when it doesn't necessarily
appear we've been jumping up and putting
new cameras but we do have fiber cabling
to a number of places and that's also
part of what's been going on in city
centre is making sure that we can have
cabling going to
the places that we will need to put
cameras in
and adapt to it
right so i've got councillor arnold was
next did you
talk to me
the money thing
to access any outside funding for this
yes it's really sort of uh
a community thing as opposed to just
city council i know i know we are the
community but you know like iot
with your premises and business people
as well perhaps in certain areas
mr chairman i haven't necessarily been
out looking for other funding partners
but there are certainly opportunities
where
i guess other community
or
like businesses where they have
public space cameras may wish to be able
to contribute
the privacy act and how you actually
manage and protect those cameras is
obviously or protect the images that you
save or what you
save is for a purpose is i guess one of
the challenges um and that's one of the
advantages
that we've had to a certain degree is
that the camera gear has set at the
police station so the only people who
can see our current camera is are
actually the police cameras um
no i haven't been out there and or had
any discussions with other parties
councillor la loathing miss coote and
miss mr cook
thanks cheer i guess uh feedback for the
um
the stakeholder representatives to
consider
is
following on from the presentation of
police and their suggestion that the
area covered could be much wider than
what we're looking now it would be
useful if we were able to get a report
that looked at it in a staged approach
as we bite off each section of the town
and doable lots bearing in mind the
tremendous capital expenditure that
we're facing currently
now that is that's that's a very wise
thought um right um
just
ah kiera um
just in regards to the cameras and fit
for purpose um is there are they
exploring to take a stage approach or
um are they testing certain
camera technology i mean it's like
anything
it changes all the time i'm just looking
how we are able to
continue to be update you know
technology
savvy
thanks mr chairman really good question
about how you actually keep up to date i
guess the first thing that i'm promoting
in my timeline is to make sure that we
actually correctly scope
sorry we understand the problem that
we're actually trying to solve and then
scope the project to make sure we can
deliver and that can be by staging it by
technology and making sure that what you
actually implement is what you want
you are able to buy
an amazing range of tools
some of those come up at costs and some
of those will be harder to maintain but
you have to i guess look at that and
make sure that what you're getting is
what it is actually solving the problem
that you have
okay thank you for that um miss cook
yes through you mr chair um
mr pearson it seems to me that one of
the first things you have to
that we might have to do
is establish what exactly
is available within the community at the
moment not talking about what we have
but what is there
with private businesses etc etc so that
we're not putting cameras or duplicating
things that are being done by others
if we're going to make our money work
smarter are we doing an audit of what
already exists
um
mr chair another good question that um
one of the issues that we face is that
it's the privacy requirements that
you are only allowed to store image for
the purpose that you say you you are
and
those individual companies or businesses
that are collecting imagery need to be
able to if they wish to send it on to
somebody be able to do that for what
purpose
so the use of private
based
cctv is typically not what sits within a
public space
camera
i do definitely do believe that council
could gain benefit from
i guess having a system that is able to
manage the park system and other areas
of council so that we actually have i
guess the expertise in house to have to
do those things
but we shouldn't necessarily cover areas
where there's good cctv already i don't
want to duplicate
but one of the things i think the police
do struggle with and but they do achieve
is if they need to go out there and hunt
in the community to find the images lots
of people have images that are
cameras pointing down streets and all
sorts of stuff for whatever reason that
aren't necessarily always obvious to
everybody but they typically find images
that they're looking for it may not be
the qual
quality and typically the police are
looking for something to be able to
um trace that
sequence of events as quickly as they
can do
that in part does answer my question
because i think
what's in my mind is that there's a
difference between
um
our supporting cameras to do the things
like
face recognition or
number plate recognition but also the
incident or problem solving thing a
crime has been committed how do we do it
and i'm not sure
whether that's where our money is best
invested that's in my head but i'm
willing to be convinced differently
so
in this audit is that what or
the work that you're going to do is that
part of the question and answer process
that we'll go through i would believe so
the first thing is to make sure we
understand what we want to achieve which
is the problem and and if it means let's
have an audit of this of where the
cameras are and what we know then that's
absolutely fine that's achievable
council cricket
thank you mr chair um to my mind um the
problem that we're trying to solve is
actually really quite simple uh it's in
the interest of public safety and
especially in that really uh dense inner
city hot spot area that we're investing
multi-million dollars across two major
projects of the streetscape and icl it's
really really clear to me that with the
height and foot traffic and the
heightened amount of people that will be
knocking around there and the
entertainment value that will be part of
that restarting the heart
the problem that we're going to want to
solve is the fact that we currently have
no visibility we've got no visibility
over the assets got no visibility over
the people we've got no visibility or
effects or a one really shoddy camera
that i've unfortunately had the well
fortunately and unfortunately had the
opportunity to view from the watch house
obviously not on the right side of it
not on the wrong side of it
um so um and i remember being there and
actually looking at that camera and its
footage and going oh my goodness i can't
believe that this is all that we can see
from a public safety perspective in that
cbd so i would hand on heart be really
glad to see this happen i know that
councillor pollinger and councillor
clark have had this on the radar for a
really long time as well as myself so
if nobody has moved those then i would
be perfectly happy to do so
okay thank you for that
thank you for seconding that uh just one
comment from the chair look
um you raised a good point alex and and
looking at the being on the
uh city city street uh escape committee
um
we that's gonna become very real soon
and it's gonna be amazing it's seriously
it's gonna be just spectacular
but unfortunately because it's so good
it's going to be open to vandalism and
that's that's what i really fear i mean
the whole of east street don street you
have these beautiful
rain gardens you've got furniture you've
got all sorts of stuff
now
that's just asset protection let alone
anyone people being there so now you
raise a good point alex okay that's been
moved and seconded got cancer amazon
just a quick question i'm just wondering
whether the stakeholder group should
include a member from the maori wardens
as well because they also do a lot of
community patrol stuff um assistance to
the police yeah i think i think um
what i'd like to do is with the
recommendations is that it
says here it wants to confirm
uh the stakeholder holder representative
i'd like to first have the meeting first
say we note if we amend that to note the
counselor stakeholder representatives
and then come back
to council with with those
alterations because really it it is work
in progress and i think
we don't want to if we confirm it that
yeah
there could be other people that need to
be on board so if people have happy with
that alteration the mover
oh i'd be happy with that um
mr chair to um say that we're going to
come back with a confirmed list as that
list that has been presented may not yet
be exhaustive such as marty wardens may
want to be included okay so we'll change
that if we can change that to note the
counselor stakeholder representative
said okay with the secondary yeah
okay so i'll put that promotion all
those in favor
hi
against that is carrie thank you very
much
it now takes us to the activities report
which is
full of activity
you'd hope
and we have
our activity man steve
thank you mr chair good afternoon
councillors your worship um
just take the activities report has read
i'll be talking on behalf of both the
leisure and recreation and the
infrastructure
services area and between michael and i
will do our best to answer any questions
you might have in that area
just some key points to draw your
attention to this month obviously splash
palace have achieved their pool safe
accreditation again which is um great
for our community
however we've noted in there that we are
having some significant recruitment
issues at the moment um much like the
rest of the country in this sector
and so what our team are doing is
looking at pulling together a unique
and we're hopefully a successful
training package that focuses on young
people's careers
and i'm certainly a byproduct of the
pool sector i started out as a lifeguard
some 20 odd years ago and we want to
start creating career pathways for our
young people and so we think this is a
great opportunity to
promote and push this as a great area to
work
a great chance to work with our
community and a good start into local
government
we're also
working on as you'll see the numbers are
related to hydroslide use
um
generally splash palace's numbers are
recovering um recovering slowly but
recovering
however we were looking at the hydro
slide numbers and we are going to be
putting some re-engagement with this
activity
packages together and this is this will
occur post the close down which
commences later this month
um and so once we reopen splash palace
we hope to have a package of services
and opportunities to get people back
into the facility to get them back into
loving swimming and to get them back
onto the hydro slide so we'll come back
to you with what that looks like later
terms of the parks team have made some
great progress and obviously we've been
able to open in the last period of time
um the umbrella installation
uh which was i think really well
received
and also um some really great success
stories coming out of costello
and the legacy that's given that
community
finally in a summary of the operations
from the infrastructure area
um it has been a really busy month and i
think the team have provided a really
good summary
of the activities that they've been
doing across our infrastructure assets
and obviously a particular interest to
the community this week is around stead
street and the completion of that stage
of the project
and i have my team that are going to be
on site are talking to the contractors
every day now about the reopening on
friday and we'll be communicating via
facebook via the internet
uh sorry website and also via media
release about the the opening and so
to that i'm happy to either pass to
michael for any further comments or
happy to take any questions
okay uh questions counselors
no questions just lots of good news in
there
congratulations around the pool say for
your accreditation that's really cool
all right council o'clock
can't let this go with at least one
question
um in relation to the pump track at tara
just um just a couple of things i noted
in the um public announcement that
you're going to
plant about 1400 native trees when's
that done is that an awesome task
yes um
my parks team are right behind me they
could actually give you the exact
details rather than trying to give you a
summary
and the other issue steve was the issue
of i had a local resident there's no
secret about this is tim frampton said
that he was prepared to
pay for some uh either tables or
barbecue areas and then is that
something that the park people are
interested in having some sort of
private sector input as well
yeah look thank you councillor clark um
in terms of the plannings they are
occurring and i think we have just been
waiting for the right environmental
conditions and i do know that the team
have been talking with a number of
members of the community about how they
might contribute to the ongoing
development of the costello park area so
and we know
mr frampton is one of those people we've
been talking to
excellent thank you
thanks councillor clark for the
questions
anybody
right well thank you steve
um
recommendations are
we have six recommendations we received
the report
note the approval of grant funding from
the ilt foundation note the receipt of
pull safe accreditation
2022 not the progress made on the new
installation of the umbrella sculpture
note the progress made on the
costello pump
park pump track project and also
acknowledged with increasing cremation
numbers and increase in resources
planned for this service so i'm going to
have someone
move that is that councilor abbott
thank you moving those seconded
counselor skill
i'm going to put that motion all those
in favor
against that is carried
thank you um now we
gonna move to
public excluded
can i have someone please move we're
going to publicly excluded thank you
councillor scout
you